so I don't know if sociopaths recognize  that they are evil  um we would have to get someone who's  you know studied this topic to talk  about this specifically but when we look  at Washington DC it has the highest per  capital sociopaths than almost anywhere  else in the United States and there also  is a theory that what Hunter Biden is  doing is trying to get some sort of  redemption against the father who wasn't  there for him or might have potentially  hurt him before and this is Hunter Biden  kind of releasing a lot of this  information getting it out there to the  general public on purpose that's one of  the theories out there in order to hurt  his father and and get some kind of  Justice